after a bit of a delay control's
next-gen version control ultimate
edition has
finally released control is one of my
favorite games of the last generation
but it is
undeniable that it was really pushing
those systems hardware
even on a ps4 pro that game had some
serious long loading times and some bad
frame pacing thankfully control ultimate
edition seems to be living up to the
game's true potential
offering a 60 frames per second
performance mode
and a 30 frames per second ray tracing
mode both of which run
extremely well we'll be showing off some
comparisons of the ps5 version with both
the ps4 and ps4 pro version
as well as some loading time tests we're
going to be showing the game booted up
from
launch into the main menu and then from
the main menu to loading up the game
if you enjoyed this video give us a like
and sub so that we can keep making more
videos like this one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i want to quickly point out something on
this next one it might look like they're
not synced up properly they actually are
i time them to exactly when i press the
button but the ps4 versions are so slow
that they actually
take a moment to register so it might
look like they're out of sync but trust
me
they are not that is just how much
faster
the ps5 version really is
fair warning this is gonna be
weirder than usual
can't be helped
you called me so here i am
i know i shut you out sometimes
i'm always glad to hear from you
it's just that i get my hopes up
so many times it's led to nothing
i found nothing
it's like we live
in a room and there's a poster on the
wall
hello anyone here
federal bureau of control
all these years i've been looking for
them and they were hiding in plain sight
hello hey
excuse me
[Music]
there you are you are here about the job
janitor's assistant
you need to go to the interview
go that way to the elevator
elevator that way got it
very good janitor part of me
you'll work for me you can say i sent
you
if they don't hire you either you're
no hell of it there'll be work for the
axe
take them behind the sound
okay now i have a gun
something's coming
this threat an attack
duty as director
keep the bureau safe
did you hear that
it's the dead man right after the
pyramid spoke to me and it was just
noise and
i understood every word
and this gun's alive you know what
i'm happy happy to be here
[Music]
secure line of communication
[Music]
guidelines
that's the dead man
[Music]
foreign